okay
he's only just received his ballot paper
but vastly crispy has already decided
he'll be voting to strike with other
Junior doctors he says things can't go
on as they are with the United
Department have 150 patients waiting to
be seen it is heartbreaking it's very
difficult situation to find ourselves in
there is no privacy there is no dignity
to patients who are either lying on the
floor sat on a chair or lying on a
trolley this is not the way we want to
practice medicine he says strikes are
the last resort we must take industrial
action we want to save our profession if
we want to increase our pay and improve
our working conditions but most
importantly if we want to be able to
save the NHS and care for our patients
from here in West Yorkshire to
Shropshire where Simon day works as a
paramedic staff describe a Health
Service in crisis an average day
will involve
some amount of delay at hospital
um
when you convey a patient and a good day
would be an hour or maybe two hours
a bad day has become when you spend your
entire shift with one patient outside
the hospital
Simon will join a picket line again
tomorrow but as the government
introduced plans for new laws to limit
industrial action unions reacted angrily
to comments about the last ambulance
strike employers could not reach
agreement nationally for minimum safety
levels during recent strikes and health
officials were left guessing at the
likely minimum coverage making
contingency planning almost impossible
and putting everyone's constituents
lives at risk
his words described by one Union as an
attack on ambulance workers
and more strikes seem likely as the
government continues to refuse to talk
about pay for this year
the number of Staff in the NHS has
increased in recent years and yet the
government say that's not translating to
outcomes could you and your colleagues
deliver any more than you do currently
no no we can't whether it's paramedics
nurses or doctors we do not have the
capacity or the strength to continue
working at the stands that we're working
at at the moment and that's why as the
health secretary visited workers at a
111 Center the rift between government
and unions was looking increasingly
difficult to heal Becky Johnson Sky News
Leeds